[Music]
once upon a time on the island of sicily
there was a race that ran right through
your village
[Music]
it was glorious it was beautiful it was
clearly planned before safety was a
consideration
[Music]
the targer florio was founded in sicily
by a speed loving fellow named vincenzio
florio in 1906 and it enthralled the
racing world for decades to come
but this was no ordinary race it took
place in the mountains outside of
palermo racers encountered bandits
wolves 500-plus hairpin turns on roads
that hadn't changed since togas were in
fashion
the course went straight through towns
and villages with no barricades or
warnings
the first year a driver named alessandro
cagno won it took him nine hours and his
average speed was 30 miles an hour
the targa florio ran for 71 years titans
of the car world like mario andretti
competed but a growing realization that
the race was crazy dangerous led to it
being shut down in 1977
it was the longest running car race in
the world at the time
today the grandstand outside palermo
sits empty
but evidence of the race is everywhere
peaking out in the beautiful landscape
the targa florio became synonymous with
a long and grueling race in the years
after its end tribute targets have
popped up across the world but true
racing enthusiasts know it all began
here
[Music]